former Indiana governor and current
president of Purdue University mitch
Daniels has some things to say about the
use and abuse of technology and big data
he has just written an op-ed in the
Washington Post titled someone is
watching you he joins us tonight from
Purdue University in West Lafayette
Indiana governor thanks for being here
why I'll write this up n it was
something of a surprise to us Brett here
how much we knew about our students and
and we're beginning to discover ways we
can use it to their benefit we want to
do that let them know things that would
be that correlate with decade' academic
success and their and their progressing
better here at Purdue but at the same
time we can we can tell that there could
be misuses of that sort of data and I
wrote it just because I know there are
institutions of all kinds who are now in
possession of information in enormous
quantities and we're all going to have
some questions to ask ourselves about
you know making sure we do the right
thing not the wrong thing with it
yeah that line between privacy and what
you could use with that data obviously
is is something we deal with in this
op-ed you say people serene in their
assurance that they know what is best
for others we'll have to stop and ask
themselves on what authority they became
the nudge and the great approvers many
of us will have to stop and ask whether
our good intentions are caring as past
boundaries where privacy and individual
autonomy should still prevail I mean
that is a fact not only on college
campuses but in what we're dealing with
with these big tech companies and what
they know about all of us and in
government and in many other walks of
life there are many people and it always
of course is motivated by what they
believe are good intentions who think
they know what's best for others and
armed with the these mountains of new
information they will be discovering the
patterns that they would like to
encourage others to to follow that that
produce what in the in the nudges I is a
good result so this is something I think
to be careful about
now there's somewhere as I say between
helping a struggling student identifying
a struggling student and connecting them
with a tutor and really shoving people
into behaviors that somebody has decided
are preferable there's a line and we
ought to be we ought to be debating it
in the individual institutions and
collectively you know I just want to get
your thoughts about a couple of things
one is we're getting ready for these tet
this testimony up on Capitol Hill
Congress with big tech companies
Facebook Google testifying before
Congress and there's really
consideration about regulation where do
you think that goes well we all we
always thought to regulate with great
great caution and and thought but this
may be an area there are certain you
know certainly antitrust and the
suspicion of bigness is not without its
foundation in American history and we
have set up various boundaries beyond
which we don't think institutions should
should grow and sprawl and it's hard not
to notice the incredible concentration
in that industry it has economic
consequences and now we know it has
major societal consequences when that
much information is in that few hands
two more things one is you're
historically a big deficit Hawk somebody
who's concerned about the deficit and
debt for a long time you talked about it
just been through this whole omnibus
spending issue what are your thoughts on
that and where the country is heading
I'm very troubled you know it it
shouldn't escape people's notice there
was a massive amount of the discussion
debate and there should have been about
a tax bill that may over ten years
increase the deficit by a trillion
dollars not to be sneezed at but when
you're already at twenty trillion that's
it's only the percentage that it is
right on its heels Congress happily and
cheerfully passed a two trillion dollar
addition to spending we
but we finally found something people
there can get together on and and
compromise on but it was probably the
wrong thing and the the looming debt
that we have built is is a economic
Menace the biggest one to this country
and the opinion of many of us and to our
future prosperity it's also a without
question a immorally question do be
esteem to dump on the next generation
bills not for money that was borrowed
and invested in their future but for
money that their elders borrowed and
spent on themselves and you know the
problem here bread is I keep telling
people the cans getting heavier and
we're running out of Road and quickly
this weekend is the NCAA Final Four
Condoleezza Rice has been asked to head
up a committee looking at the NCAA
basketball and and some of the problems
they've been having you've written about
that as well your thoughts as we head
into this this weekend it's a little
like the big data column I'm all
questions and very few answers the one
thing I know and and and think is very
hard to argue with is that the status
quo in Division one basketball needs a
needs a lot of repair we've seen
corruption we've seen the the game in
essence semi-professional eyes doll
though the people the young men who are
creating all the value don't get paid
for it and something really needs to
change I'm so glad that the NCAA has
acted and commissioned a group led by
someone like condi rice with her
tremendous judgment and credibility
there's some other good people on there
in the column I threw out three ideas
but they're probably the wrong ideas I
don't pretend to know the exact answer
but we need to reinstate the the the air
really of genuine student-athletes and
those who really are only attending
college to pursue an athletic career and
are pretending to be students with the
complicity of their institutions ought
to be paid above the table in some sort
of minor league in my
looking forward to a great tournament
there's some there for great teams there
this weekend all credit to them but the
system as a whole should not go on as it
is much longer governor daniels we
appreciate your time tonight thanks for
having me